le blanchemaison bonjour bonjour heureux
de vous retrouver ce matin sur rtl
france alors pour bien comprendre quelle
est la nature de cet engagement entre la
syrie et l'iran
c'est une déclaration purement politique
puisque on ne dit rien sur le fond des
choses mais c'est surtout une manoeuvre
diplomatique iranienne comme vous venez
de le dire c'est le nouveau ministre
iranien des affaires étrangères monsieur
amir abdolahian qui a fait une petite
tournée dans les pays du proche orient
il a assisté à une réunion
internationale à bagdad et il s'est
rendu et s'est rendu en syrie pour
voir les alliés en réalité de l'iran et
notamment le président bachar al assad
et les deux pays étant sous sanctions
américaines ont fait un communiqué
disant que ils allaient unir leurs
efforts pour résister aux sanctions
américaines
en réalité c'est un tout petit peu
inquiétant parce que ça pourrait vouloir
dire et d'ailleurs ce que dit le porte
parole dans votre sujet le porte parole
iranien le confirmerait que dans le fond
l'iran considère qu'il ya peu de chances
d'aboutir à un accord à vienne pour la
remise en marche de l'accord du 15
juillet 2015 sur le nucléaire iranien
est en effet le gouvernement iranien a
passé dans insisté sur le fait que les
américains devaient s'engager à lever
toutes les sanctions et non pas
progressivement mais elles élevées tout
avant que l'iran ne rentre dans ses
obligations de l'accord en question que
donald trump a dénoncé en 2018 le
gouvernement actuel de monsieur raïssi
le gouvernement iranien de monsieur
raïssi réputé plus dur
probablement
va insister lorsque les négociations
vont reprendre à vienne sur le fait que
tant que les américains ne lève pas les
sanctions et bien il ne peut pas y avoir
d'accord comme 2 côté les américains
ajoute quelques codicille à l'accord de
2015 en disant il faut quand même pu
ouvrir une perspective pour discuter de
ce qui succédera à la corde 2015 et puis
surtout pour parler des sujets
balistiques et ça les iraniens et le
gouvernement actuel iranien n'est pas du
tout prêt à le faire alors que l'autre
quels sont les moyens d'action des deux
pays
est très faible les moyens d'action
politique bien sûr mais sur le plan
concret la syrie a besoin de pétrole
bien sûr l'iran peut lui en fournir même
s'il est si ce pétrole est sous embargo
de toute manière la russie les journées
a également de carburant et à part cela
il n'y a pas grand chose à faire parce
que tant que les états unis auront une
monnaie dominante dans le monde les
trois quarts des échanges mondiaux sont
libellés en dollars par conséquent
lorsque les états unis mettent des
sanctions c'est sanction s'applique de
façon
extraterritoriale puisque toutes
entreprises dans le monde qui utilisent
des dollars pour les transactions peut
se trouver sanctionnés aux états unis
évidemment c'est tout à fait exorbitant
du droit commun mais c'est comme ça que
les choses se passent et contre cela les
iraniens et les syriens ne peuvent pas
grand chose il faudrait mais ça ne peut
pas se faire à court terme que un
certain nombre de flux commerciaux se
libérer dans d'autres devises que le
dollar est en quelques mots claude à ce
que les sanctions constituent une
politique étrangère efficace
alors ça c'est une question très
importante
effectivement dans beaucoup de cas on a
considéré que les sanctions n'étaient
pas efficaces et surtout par rapport à
l'objectif qu'elle s'était fixé en
général lorsqu'on met des sanctions sur
un pays sûr un gouvernement c'est pour
obliger ce gouvernement à changer de
politique et c'est cela se produit
extrêmement rarement en revanche l'effet
des sanctions et de peser sur la
population de rendre la vie des
populations beaucoup plus difficile ils
les élites se débrouillant de toute
façon pour contourner plus ou moins
l'application des sanctions donc on peut
en effet discuter de la pertinence des
sanctions dans les relations
internationales actuelles il y en a de
plus en plus
simplement alors sa justification
peut-être que il est dans le fond
peut-être préférable de mettre des
sanctions que de faire la guerre mais
dans certains cas les états unis ont
fait les deux à la fois
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre éclairage ce matin un édito
diplo à retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux avec vous claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales